[Musique]
debout papa il faut y aller
les éléphants besoin nous regarder ça un
bébé d'un pépé un petit bémol c'est quoi
ça une tête que seule une mère peut
aimer monsieur beaucoup d'entre nous
vous trouve séduisant je parlais
l'éléphant tas jusqu'à demain soir pour
régler ce problème moi et moi
disparaître ses oreilles du monde
pourquoi tu me regardes bonjour bébé
d'ambo bienvenue au cirque
on fait tous partie de la même famille
du plus petit au plus grand
allo
vous possédez quelque chose
d'extrêmement rare
[Musique]
un mélange de merveilleux
de magie venez avec moi
[Musique]
ensemble sur les ailes de cet éléphant
nous irons très loin
[Musique]
tu es miraculeux de bois courage mon
grand c'est exactement comme une
répétition par le jeu de lumière le feu
et la foule
tu vas y arriver
paul bento